let's uh let's talk about the revolution
yeah let's do it we got this we have the
story from fox news lapd station fire
bomb attack caught on camera as suspect
tosses molotov cocktail at building
suspect taken into custody lapd to panga
division station but motive unknown
that's just the story it could be
nothing i mean you guys have certainly
heard of stories like this throughout
your your life right you're seeing more
and more of this and um with bitcoin
it's peace peace peaceful it's it
promotes love and promotes uh community
whereas fiat money this is a fiat money
story this is what happens when when you
have a an economy this is this family
this is what happens
when somebody works for 80 hours in a
week and then says i need to pay my rent
and then a month goes by and he can't
afford to buy food even though he just
worked 80 hours it's happened because
money is literally just paper this
happens when uh you know disintegrations
happen when the entropy happens within a
system that you see it all the time like
like world wars happen and it's not just
world war pandemic happens at the same
time
you see
before the renaissance at the end of the
dark ages you see
bubonic plague you see the inquisition
you see all sorts of stuff start to
happen at the same time because we're
vibrating as a culture and a people
things are going crazy what's weird we
got we have another story i just got to
read this
officers fatally shoot man who rammed
his suv into massachusetts police
station d.a says so this is just from
today this afternoon
uh the man managed to drive through the
steel double doors he was he was the
officer shot the suspect appeared to be
a man in his early 20s after he got out
of his vehicle and aimed what appeared
to be a rifle at responding officers no
one was hurt the man was taken to saint
vincent hospital uh in worcester where
he was pronounced dead on monday the
worcester county district attorney
identified the man as zachary richardson
a leicester resident so i don't know um
if we have anything on this guy or what
his motivation was but regardless look
we we we see these stories and i think
it's fair to say
maybe they're just random attacks if we
can't read the guy's mind we don't know
but i think everything you've mentioned
the signs we're seeing pop up at all
these restaurants where people are
refusing to work
people are ready to explode they're
they're they're livid and i really do
think when you look at gas prices going
up there was this video i retweeted it
where there's a guy he felt his got 20
gallon tank 89 and he's like yo joe
biden what up
all right i'm ready to vote again and
i'm like
well look the bill comes due you print
all this money what do you think's gonna
be what's weird is that people seem to
claim that the problem is what we could
fall under the category of social
justice right for some reason the policy
makers in washington think the problem
has to do with that's the trick pronouns
or something like that whereas the
problem is the paper money but they
don't will never address this problem
because they themselves are the chief
beneficiary of the graft i think the of
the grift of the ponzi scheme i think
you guys know this occupy wall street
was legitimate early on you had
conservatives libertarians the left left
and right complaining with the big banks
you had the tea party movement upset
with the politicians you had people
ready to storm onto wall street
angry and then all of a sudden within a
couple of weeks
the protest narrative started switching
into white privilege
uh progressive stack racial hierarchies
and i would be willing to bet
um i'm not saying it's true that special
interests were like how can we get them
to stop pointing the finger at us
introduce race politics
make make the poor people point at each
other instead of at the big banks the
financial institutions and the corrupt
revolving door policies of the
government and then all of a sudden what
happened conservatives started leaving
the libertarians left right away and it
became a woke fest where people were
like the white people can't speak
anymore and then people lost interest
well look who's the most demonized of
all
in all of this
the economic bottom the ones who've been
harmed the most from this uh us dollar
reserves from the chiffon dilemma from
the facility strap like we've demonized
that
and they're called fascists and they're
called uh white supremacist nazis uh uh
you know the the ordinary
and it's like some fat truck driver from
yeah
or something yeah so
they're the ones that are demonized
because they don't want they want you to
point to the victim as that's the person
um that that you know rather than this
economic system it's it's funny how many
of these leftists who you know i used to
i've known many of them stacked by wall
street they post this this cartoon where
there's three people sitting at a table
there's a rich guy with a big stack of
cookies a working-class guy with like
two cookies and then a poor person with
like one cookie and he's like that guy
wants to steal your cookies to make them
fight each other and i'm like how do
they recognize this and then
simultaneously defend massive
multinational corporations cheer on the
fbi and joe biden it's like all of a
sudden the tribe was more important than
anything that ever presented well you've
got a good perspective on it because you
were kind of came out of that
and so did lee camp that's right
and uh you know and so he is uh voicing
these concerns
every single day in his show luke
rutkowski who we know
he's a guy who was there with his camera
and doing brilliant investigative
journalism on the scene journalism you
know but everyone in the new media space
or the alt media space uh also
marginalized also pushed to the side uh
and for this for the same reasons
because they the light will does not
want to be
shined on the actual underlying root
causes of these problems and so what we
do is similar
alt-right yeah we focus on the money
issue that's what we've been doing for
16 17 years and we've been saying this
and nothing we've said has ever been not
been borne out by by by the truth you
you guys said that the millennials are
gonna have a great century yeah and at
the gen z but uh the fourth turning may
be upon us we're seeing people attack
police stations we're saying police quit
and mass
are we not going to see a period of
tumult of violence and cast before it
gets better
um
we have the cable news which is
different from back in the 1960s or 70s
but look at documentaries about when max
was like a little kid there were like a
thousand fire bombings of
government buildings from the weather
underground and and other groups like
that the the sibanese liberation army
like it was crazy was there was there
multi-factional violence targeting each
other no they were targeting the
government right now but now it's people
against people because of course uh we
don't you know it's essentially the same
co-intel pro sort of situation you turn
the people against each other that's the
best way to control them so i've talked
about um civil war yeah and i always
preface this with it was it was the a
princeton professor who said we're in a
cold civil war it was you know the
atlantic and new york meg who mentioned
that their high probabilities you have
thucydides trap you have the the fourth
turning and what people need to
understand about the civil war is that
americans often imagine the american
civil war as their reference for what
civil war is it's not so we recently had
someone who said if it happens here
it'll be more like syria you'll get
maybe 24 or 30 factions totally
unrelated fighting with the government
and fighting with each other in areas
it'll just be chaos and bombings and
shootings and it kind of feels like
hopefully uh i'll say hopefully doesn't
happen but we're already seeing the
seeds planted of this we're seeing
various cells of antifa groups with
different names they call themselves
different things in different parts of
the country but they coordinate with
each other to go after mutual enemies
you then have right-wing militia groups
we we recently had in in portland an
armed group of
of you know fringe leftists marching
around with full blackout gear body
armor a couple of them in full black out
with body armor and rifles and they were
blocking traffic essentially doing
patrols a guy gets out you guys they
start banging on his truck he tells them
you know get out of the way
they have weapons they draw on him
according to him so he they they uh he
gets out of the truck he thought he hit
something someone goes in they smash his
windows they grab one of his left less
lethal weapons so he warns them he pulls
his gun out at low ready and says the
next person that aims at me i'm going to
shoot he's he gets put in the hospital
with some serious injuries he's got two
broken vertebrae so these groups are in
seattle and portland it's getting nuts
and you know people are on an edge this
one guy got shot twice in the chest by
one of these leftist guys and of course
you've got right-wing groups you've got
the people strumming the capital i think
we're
walking between through the doors of
different factions of
disparate ideologies some that agree
with others and some that don't ready
for for
each other the institutions that help or
the glue to hold the country together
the education institution education's
been destroyed by debt and being
overpriced so education is now no longer
available to the masses anymore it's
become a privileged amount for a few and
then you have a health care became
financialized commodified and it's
unaffordable or it's totally messed
around with
you have the infrastructure is breaking
down and all these institutions why are
they so fragile why did this all happen
because they've been hollowed out
with
these private equity groups in wall
street using all the leverage buyout and
the debt and the funny money and now
we're seeing the reaping the whirlwind
of 40 years of but
the scary thing is it's kind of like
belfast what you're describing there if
you've ever been there and understand
the story there and it's still going on
like you still see some
stuff happening there that the militia
groups um max and i were there right
during the g8 and obama obama kicked us
out of our hotel by the way we had to
move to a different hotel luke rutkowski
was there
and uh filmed films for us there
and um you know we we went by uh they
they did up that street one of the one
of the protestant areas loyalist areas
and you know they closed down the
militia
pubs
except for it was i think it was udf at
this one it was like um for sale they
were trying to clean up the militias and
like after the good friday agreement and
it there was a huge sign on the outside
of this building for sale and right next
to it handwritten not for sale property
of the udf so nobody bought it in the in
the eight years it was for sale because
they're like okay i'm not going to get
firebombed by that but that's
but
they're like
again like it's still going on the
troubles are still going on it starts
nominally with like protestant versus
catholic and you know the queen versus
like independent ireland and
and the same thing here it's like it
starts off like low-key like msnbc
versus fox and then it's like this weird
movable feast that there's no one thing
you could stick your finger on it's like
changes what their ideology is or what
the word that is a trigger word that's
gonna get you knifed in some alley right
so you know you know what's really scary
to me is that you know uh two years ago
i said things are gonna get bad yeah and
then a lot of things i said we're gonna
have it happen in january we had our our
friend jack murphy who comes on the show
every other wednesday uh he was our i
think he was our first guest um we
talked about predictions for the year
and we got some things eerily right a
bunch of fans of the show were like look
at these clips from your show in january
of last year that's freaky and uh
it's funny because it feels like we're
frogs in a pot with the water slowly
coming to a boil as much as i've been
talking about so much of this
it's like every day it seems like more
and more is happening that makes it feel
like we're actually we're in it and it's
getting worse and the scary thing is to
realize we're not wrong
well it's media pressure i don't know if
it's necessarily getting worse or just
seems like it's getting worse that's
definitely by design they want us to
think it's getting worse so we don't
focus on the fact that my facebook page
which is a great uh barometer for me and
it's always worked well um and i like
for 2016 i could see that trump was
gonna win based on what what i was
seeing
i have like half my family is democrat
and like really democrat and half the
family is republican and will only vote
republican and of course the republican
side of our military and police and the
other side are all like academics and
wiccans and stuff like that
and um the
the democrat side is like
vicious now it's it's impossible to go
on my facebook page because if one of my
republican family like leave a message
like oh i voted for trump and it's just
like an avalanche of all my like
left-wing friends my democrat friends
are just like you nazi and i'm like this
is my facebook page it's my family but
what's scary is that those people can't
explain themselves no and i i we talk to
conservatives all the time who have
i mean there's a wide range of political
ideologies outside of this tribalist
trump deranged and now without trump
it's even creepier because i don't even
know what they're mad about at this
point they're still so mad and
and so like it's a it's a terrifying
anger it's like it's the sort of anger
where like you justify all sorts of
stuff yeah like with that sort of ending
i mean these people are cheering on the
fbi and george w bush yeah that scares
me i i know hackers from back in 2010
2011 people i was hanging out with who
were anti-establishment people who were
were out in front of jails because their
buddies had been arrested by the feds
for non-crimes people who had had had
thrown parties no joke hackers who threw
parties for white nationalists because
they were hackers who were
anti-establishment these people today
are cheering on the federal government
they're they're cheering for law
enforcement they're they're
pro-establishment they're pro-democrat
they're pro-joe biden and i'm like what
happened to those people to where
they've thrown away any semblance of
principle or ideology and just said
whatever the establishment says goes
because they fear it's all going to be
taken away
so
he's talking about the elites coastal
elites the media elites they never had a
moment as they have now for many years
where
people with pitchforks and torches are
outside their home
and they're protesting and they are
frightened
uh because it was very very cozy for
decades to just be behind a wall and to
be an expert or a pundit or a part of
the elite and suddenly that's all being
ripped apart and they are frightened to
death
so they're
they're well they're calling the fbi
i know that i protested you for years
and i know that i don't i'm against the
invasiveness and the law breaking that
you're committing along with projection
but i'm not talking about rich people
i'm talking about people who slept on
the ground at occupy wall street yeah
i'm talking about people who are like 20
years old had had 10 bucks to their name
said the system is broken and we're
living on the streets are now
pro-establishment pro-fbi and so so when
when the fbi raided giuliani's office
i see all these posts from these these
these activists these hackers and these
you know and they're saying they're
cheering and they're celebrating they're
posting beer emojis and clapping and i
said whoo go fbi go go centralized
federal government law enforcement and i
was like it's so great to see how you
guys have been completely de-radicalized
i was worried about you for a minute
listen it's it's projection it's also
look on on the one side you have
90 000 overdose deaths last year in
america that's on the one side on the
other hand side that's the same sort of
thing that's that's a that's an abused
person that's somebody who's abused and
needing like um their violent father to
come smash somebody's head in for them
like you want
the needing a thug to beat somebody up
or to remove their um freedom like
that's like that's something wrong
that's something like mentally
psychologically wrong with you and i
think there's we're an abused population
from a you know and so what you're
talking about there would be a mass
psychosis yeah it's a psychological uh
problem right like this like
what happened with germany why did
germany go like that what they were
humiliated right they were humiliated
population post-world war one well we're
a humiliated population as well here and
i think um you know we have these two
msnbc versus fox and they're like
pushing the two well msnbc's ratings are
totally in the gutter now like a
fraction of foxes but it's not it's not
just fox it's just
i i i think they're even if you watch
fox if you're getting like tucker
carlson you're getting a just more
discerning world view albeit far from
perfect but tucker does have on
opposition personalities no one else
does this thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time